all right miss Erin this season on one
calls the heart we are so excited the
telephone is coming to town I still
can't believe the telephone is coming to
Hope Valley so to celebrate that we want
to play a game with you called et phone
home Valley a teen phone Oh Valley there
you go
Scratchy who takes the best selfies Paul
Green probably takes the most probably
takes good selfies he's photogenic where
is your go-to selfie spot on set blue
wall there's a number of exteriors that
are painted blue
I like those or we get some really
magical sunsets on set so just take
advantage of that as a backdrop who was
the last co-star you texted what did you
say to each other let's let's pull it
out pascale talking about her birthday
can we send her a selfie okay three
three I'm gonna send this right now
who's on their phone the most on set me
may be doing what just know try to stay
in touch with family or friends
is there a caste group chat I have a
group chat with Lori and Pascal and we
dish what's in those texts sometimes
we'll send each other photos or I don't
know every now and again we'll send each
other a weird tweet that we read things
like that who from the cast prefers a
phone call over a text so Lori and I
text a lot and sometimes we'll be
texting for a long time and it'll just
get like I count with the thumbs anymore
so we just it's like I'm sorry I
couldn't text anymore can we just finish
this conversation over the phone the
old-fashioned an old-fashioned way yes
and Pascal and I will FaceTime quite a
bit because she's so far away in
Vancouver I'm not kidding
these are some of my dearest friends on
set so it's really important to me to
stay in touch with all of them what was
the last thing you miss Erin googled
embarrassing maps of the United States
showing how different regions pronounce
the same word or have different words
for things that's fascinating bull I'm
originally from the Northeast grew up in
South Florida and apparently they're the
only two areas that call tennis shoe
whose sneakers what is something you
wish Elizabeth could Google oh I wish
Elizabeth could Google something
baby-related probably like how to invent
a better diapers a song totally has your
phone ever gone off while filming oh I
did have one embarrassing moment where I
said sorry and I think I said it in kind
of a Canadian like sori and Siri was
like yes may I help you or whatever
series is and I just ignored Siri
finished the scene and then quickly ran
to my phone didn't you know turn her off
you don't carry it on you one year no
but I'd probably I stash my phone in a
lot of set pieces so you know when I'm
teaching in the school I'll put my phone
in a desk drawer or you know behind
cushions what is your most frequently
used emoji
laughing at a diagonal with a lot of
tears who do you think you send out the
most to glory three emojis to describe
season six there's a new one with like
little hearts all around the face so
that's one probably the baby emoji and
you know that fabulous girl in the red
dress
Oh dancing or striking a pose or
something can I ask why there's a dance
it's just that's what came to mind first
[Applause]
[Music]